i've been thinking a lot recently about
microcosms because recently in my own
life understanding what a microcosm is
has really helped me live a better life
day to day and i really hope that if
you're in a rough place you'll consider
what i'm about to say and hopefully you
can gain some new ideas so that you can
you know trend your life in a better
direction okay so a microcosm is defined
as a community place or situation
regarded as encapsulating in miniature
the characteristic qualities or features
of something much larger feel free to
pause the video and really soak that in
and while you're soaking that in let me
ask you a question what's the difference
between life and living you know life
itself may seem like a simple enough
concept because we talk about it all the
time i have a life you have a life it's
the thing we're all a part of and all
seem to have but if i ask you to
describe what your life is it's a little
bit more difficult to do so because
there's so much involved in life and
your life is kind of just everything
that has to do with you your family
situation growing up your family
situation right now it might be the job
that you have the job that you want to
have your hopes and dreams for the
future your trauma and regret of the
past every idea that bounces around your
skull or has bounced around in your
skull life is everything
and since it describes everything it
also kind of describes nothing in
particular it's an all-encompassing idea
that is basically just a theme and a
concept something we're all familiar
with but none of us truly understand
living on the other hand is something
that we experience something that you're
doing right now living is something
you've always done and something you
always will do because by definition
before you were living was before you
were you and when you stop living you
will stop being you
so you and living are the same thing you
don't know what it's like to not live in
some ways though your life and your
living are not unlike each other they
both deal with similar people places and
things they both have familiar faces
people you know and love or strongly
dislike and want to avoid both have
dealt and will deal with similar
emotions similar feelings
tendencies actions and reactions but
despite their commonalities one remains
a stranger something we can only look at
through abstraction through memories we
recall but can't see and places we'll go
but never be because no matter how much
we think about our life
it will never make sense to us
completely you know it's impossible to
see it all at once it's impossible to
grasp what our life is we only see
fragments and patterns
and themes and in a lot of ways that's
exactly what life is it's a pattern of
moments strung together it's the
overarching theme of decisions that
we've made in days like today so if we
take a step back and we think about our
entire life
and we don't like what we see we're
basically saying we don't like the
pattern
we don't like the theme if life is
everything all at once and living is the
day-to-day then by definition each day
is a microcosm of life each day we live
is a situation that encapsulates in
miniature the characteristic qualities
or features of our life and when we
start to realize this we'll start to
realize that life isn't really something
we can interact with
we don't have access to our life
the only thing that we have access to is
living playing it out day by day
decision by decision and our tendencies
and our impulses to do certain things
are essentially the only thing that we
can influence when it comes to our
existence so what does this all mean
well it means that if you survey your
life you look at the direction that
you're heading you look at the things
that you dislike about your life and
about yourself maybe you don't like the
fact that you never have the motivation
to go to the gym or you can't seem to
focus at work and it leads to poor job
performance which leads to less money
which means that you can't put food on
the table maybe you're not proud of who
you are maybe you don't take care of
yourself maybe you have serious feelings
of regret about things you did or didn't
do in the past maybe you have wild
uncertainty about the future or you're
fairly convinced that there is no future
for you well
these things are all
life things but you don't experience
life you experience living living is
confined by constant beginnings and ends
sunrise sunset again and again and again
you are living right now and it's all
you've been doing so if there are things
that you don't like about your life then
the only thing you can do to change them
is to change the way you live today you
know maybe you're thinking i need to
quit smoking and one day i'm going to
quit smoking for the rest of my life and
i'm going to live the rest of my life
free from this nasty habit and i'm gonna
be happy and healthy all the live long
day as if that's somehow different than
not smoking today because each time we
wake up we're confronted with an
opportunity to echo the familiar motif
that's become the central theme or we
can realize that our entire life is
crafted in moments like these so are we
gonna continue to water the same tree
or are we gonna plant a new seed and i
swear i'm not trying to be dr seuss here
a lot of that [ __ ] rhymed but hopefully
you get what i'm saying there is no
difference between going to the gym
today and going to the gym for the rest
of your life because going to the gym
for the rest of your life is not
something you can do it's never been
something you've had the ability to do
going to the gym for the rest of your
life is going to the gym today
a big thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video you guys know that
i'm a big fan of ag-1 and have been
taking it every single morning for about
two years ag-1 supports your energy
focus gut health immunity and mental
clarity all without the need to take
multiple products or pills and i really
do feel better when i'm taking it and i
think that's because there's basically
no competing with the amount of vitamins
and nutrients in one scoop of this stuff
and the fact that it's sourced from
whole food ingredients and superfoods
means that it's extremely bioavailable
unlike so many multivitamins that you
can buy off store shelves ag-1 comes in
a form that is super useful to your body
and your body just soaks it up goes yum
yum yum thank you so much i feel great
now so if you guys are interested in
joining me in this very simple health
optimization habit then if you use my
link in the description below you also
get a year's supply of the vitamin d3
and k2 complex which i also use every
single morning and you also get five
ag-1 travel packs with your first
purchase so once again use my link in
the description below to take advantage
of this offer and thank you so much to
athletic greens for sponsoring this
video guys if you liked this video and
you got something out of it it would be
a huge help if you actually hit the
literal like button because that helps
the video rank better and if you're on
instagram anyways consider following the
better ideas instagram but if you're not
on instagram don't get instagram to
follow better ideas because you're
probably better off not being on
instagram to be honest other than that
thank you so much for watching and i'll
catch you in the next video
you